[Music]
my name is Andrea run denali on strength
and conditioning coach performance
nutritionist at the dragon not only did
the players require energy to basically
run out the whole training session or
match but the recovery focus is really
important and making sure the bodies
adapt and recover games the game train
to training yes is product range being
sent us is such a wide range of products
which we can individualize our athletes
to have products which suits their needs
example this would be some of the more
bigger guys we really need a maintain
body composition they may be on a higher
carbohydrate drink during training other
athletes will be on a calorie do such as
the hydro which which is a great product
and contains a vital electrolytes to get
through the training session so give
them a training quite hot temperatures
especially during pre-season say
important the players are refueling
during the session not only before so we
utilize the energy bars go energy gels
to replace and replenish carbohydrate in
this session but on top of that the
players have a pretty strict electrolyte
regime during the session so we'll have
individualized bottles recoveries vital
after a match and after a training
session in rugby given the high contact
on the high collisions we need to make
sure that we reduce the muscle damage
fall in and match up see we ply place
nutrition and sleep as the two key
factors to help that the favorite
products will have to be published in
the mornings really good product you
moon gives you iron and vitamin C and
daily that can help prevent illnesses
and the last thing that any actually
wanted to mister training day based on
being sick the other product which we're
loving is the weight protein after gym
truly light really easy bin to digest
and it's low calorie which which
obviously helps from a body composition
point of view the first call I made when
I got this position was assigned things
both based on the fact that although
their products are really of a high
standards they're quite strict and very
elite with their their testing or
advanced substances and I've got full
faith in their practices which signs and
support employees